david clinton has written and created
many popular technical books and video
courses
this data analytics course along with
the accompanying website and jupiter
notebooks
will help you learn data analytics in 30
days
welcome to my course i'm really glad to
have you here
and i'm even happier that you've decided
to join the
data analytics party who am i
i'm the author of more than a dozen
books on linux and aws administration
digital security and dozens of courses
on pluralsight
i've also got a fistful of articles
right here on the free code camp
news site but i just write about stuff
hopefully
when you're done with this content
you'll be out using data to change the
world
since you've already seen my claim that
this will only take you
30 days i should explain what this
actually is i'm going to show you the
tools you'll need to find and
manipulate raw data and use various
graphing tools to help you understand
and interpret it
but don't expect us to cover a full data
science curriculum here complete with
single and multi-variable calculus
algorithmic
problem solving or even machine learning
that would require a
whole lot more time and effort if that's
what you're after
check out the new data science content
that free code camp is in the process of
bringing online
there's something else you won't get
from these videos experience
once you've watched the entire course
you probably still won't be able to
do much on your own the value of actual
hands-on experience is the mistakes you
make
you know mistyping syntax not properly
understanding what your
code is doing or failing to account for
environment specific restrictions
diagnosing and working through those
mistakes is where you'll
really begin to take charge and
accomplish great things
so where will you get that experience if
you're ambitious
and you've got exciting project ideas of
your own by all means
dive in and try it out but if you think
you
still need some guidance then i've got
everything you should need on my
stories.thedataproject.net site
you can work through the exercises in
each of eight
data stories that you'll find over there
if there's a
specific skill you're looking for the
learning objectives index down here
will point you directly to the chapter
where you'll find it
all that's available for anyone and for
free
if you happen to prefer working with a
real book you can purchase the
same content in that format but don't
think anything's missing from the free
website
but right now let's talk about data
analytics
tools there are many ways to
consume data the one you choose will
reflect your specific needs
and your comfort with various skills
spreadsheets
as you probably already know are much
more than just
fancy calculators or places to keep your
household budget numbers
they also come with powerful functions
external integrations
and graphing capabilities enterprise
strength tools like tableau
splunk or microsoft's power bi are
also great for crunching numbers and
visualizing insights
which you can then share with your team
members so then what's the big deal with
python
well the python ecosystem is much much
broader than those
purpose-built tools and the python
community
makes all kinds of useful data specific
libraries and modules available
when you let python loose against your
data you've got all the resources of a
full bore industrial strength
programming language
at your fingertips it's not what you can
do with it that's the challenge
it's finding something that you can't do
okay
but what about jupiter jupiter is an
open source platform within which you
can
load your data and execute your python
code
it's a lot like a programming ide like
microsoft's visual studio
and while jupiter notebooks can be used
with a
growing number of languages and for as
many tasks as you can imagine
it's best known and loved as a host for
python data heroics once upon a time
the lines of code you'd write for your
programs would be saved to a
single text file whose name ended with a
dot py
suffix when you wanted to run your code
to see how things went
you do it from the command line or a
powerful and complicated
source code editor like visual studio
but for
anything to work it all had to work
that would make it harder to
troubleshoot when something didn't go
according to spec
but it would also make it a lot harder
to play around with
specific details just to see what
happens
and it also made it tough to share live
versions of your code
across the internet as we'll soon see
jupyter notebooks
let you run your code a single line at a
time
or altogether that flexibility makes it
easier
to understand your code and when things
go wrong
to troubleshoot it notebooks by the way
are
json based files that effectively move
the
processing environment for just about
any data oriented programming code
from your server or workstation to your
web browser
you can download jupyter to your pc or a
private server
and access the interface through any
browser with network access
or you can run notebooks on third-party
hosting services like
google's co-laboratory or for a cost
cloud providers like amazon's sagemaker
studio notebooks
or microsoft's as your notebook jupiter
comes in
three flavors the two you're most likely
to encounter are
classic notebooks and the newer jupiter
lab
both run nicely within your browser but
jupiter lab comes with
more extensions and lets you work with
multiple notebook files and terminal
access within a single browser tab
i'll be using the classic notebook
environment for the demos in this course
but there's usually no problem
transferring notebooks between versions
the third flavor just to be complete is
jupiter hub
a server version built to provide
authenticated notebook access to
multiple users you can serve up to 100
or so users from a
single cloud server using the littlest
jupiter hub
for larger deployments involving
clusters of servers
you'd probably be better off with a
kubernetes version known as
zero to jupiter hub with kubernetes but
all that's way beyond the scope of this
course
our next job is to build our work
environment
assuming you've decided to host jupiter
on your own machine
you'll need python installed the good
news
is that most operating systems come with
python pre-installed
you can confirm that you've got an
up-to-date version of python
by opening a command prompt and typing
python dash dash
version or sometimes python 3
dash dash version if python is installed
you'll probably see something like this
just make sure you've got python
3 installed and not the deprecated and
insecure python 2.
if you do need to install python
manually you're best off using python's
official documentation
that'll be the most complete and
up-to-date source available that'll work
with
whatever operating system you're on it's
important to note
that not all python versions even those
from
3.x will necessarily behave quite the
way you expect
you may for instance find that you need
a library written for version 3.9
but that there's no way to get it
working on your 3.7
system upgrading your system version to
3.9
might work out well for you but it could
also cause some unexpected and
unpleasant consequences it's hard to
know when a particular python library
might also be needed by your core
operating system
if you pull the original version of the
library he might end up disabling
the os itself and don't think it won't
happen
i crippled my own os that way just a few
months ago
one solution is to run python for your
project within a special
virtual environment that's isolated from
your larger os
that way you can install all the
libraries and versions you like
without having to worry about damaging
your work system
you can do this using a full-scale
virtual container
running a docker or as i prefer lxd
image or on a standalone aws cloud
instance
but you can also use python's own the
end
module you'll want to read the official
documentation for the
virtual environment instructions
specific to your host os
whichever version of jupiter you choose
if you decide to install and
run it locally the jupiter project
officially recommends
doing it through the python anaconda
distribution
and its binary package manager conda
various guides to doing that are
available for various os hosts
but this official page is a good place
to start as you can see
though the python pip package manager is
also an option
once all that's done you should be able
to open a notebook
right in your browser and get right down
to work
for me a notebook's most powerful
feature is the way you can run
subsets of your code within individual
cells
this makes it easier to break down long
and complex programs into
easily readable and executable snippets
with a cell selected clicking the run
button will
execute just that cell's code note how
the box on the left gets a number
representing the sequential position of
the execution
as you become more familiar with jupiter
you'll probably get
in the habit of executing cells using
control
and enter rather than a mouse click you
can insert
a new cell right after the one that's
currently selected by clicking the plus
button
the up and down arrows move cells as you
might expect
up and down cells by default are
formatted to handle code python 3 in my
case
but they can also be set for markdown
which can be handy for
documenting your notebooks or making new
sections easier to find
a single hashtag in markdown for
instance represents a top level
selection title
executing the cell will print the text
to match your formatting instruction
the precise locations and appearance of
the buttons you'll use to get this stuff
done
will vary between the different jupiter
versions
but all the basic functions are
universally available
whatever values your code creates will
remain in the
kernel memory until the output from a
particular cell or for the entire kernel
are cleared this lets you rerun previous
or
subsequent cells to see what impact a
change might have
it also means resetting your environment
for a complete start over
is as easy as selecting restart kernel
and clear all outputs
not all python functionality will be
available out of the box
sometimes as you saw just before you'll
need to tell python to load one or
more modules through declarations within
your code
but some modules need to be installed
manually from the host command line
before they can even be imported
for such cases python recommends their
installer program
pip or in some cases the conda tool from
the
anaconda distribution you can read more
about using pip for the
proper care and feeding of your python
system
within the helpful python documentation
site
okay here's where we get down to real
work
we're going to head out to the internet
to find reliable data
that'll help us answer a real world
question
and we'll use a public api to get the
data
then we'll examine the data to get a
feel for its current formatting
and what it'll take to fix it after
applying the necessary
formatting so our code can happily read
it
we'll merge multiple datasets together
so we can look for
correlations and then experiment with
graphing tools to find the one that
represents our data in the most
intelligible way
what's the problem we're trying to solve
i'm curious to see whether wages paid to
u.s
workers over the past 20 years have on
average
gone up assuming they have increased i'd
also like to know whether the
extra money in their pockets has also
increased their
actual standard of living to answer
those questions
we're going to access two data sets
collected
and maintained by the us government's
bureau of labor statistics
one of the many nice things about the
bureau of labor statistics usually
referred to as
bls is that they provide an api for
access from within our python scripts to
make that work
you'll need to know the bls endpoint
address
matching the specific data series you
need the
python code to initiate the request and
for
higher volume requests a bls api key
getting the series endpoint addresses
you need may take some digging around in
the
bls website however the most popular
data sets are accessible through a
single page
this shows you what that looks like
including the endpoint codes like
lns11 and a whole lot of zeros for the
civilian labor force set you can also
search for data sets on
this page searching for computer for
instance
will take you to a list that includes
the deeply tempting
average hourly wage for level 11
computer and
mathematical occupations in austin round
rock texas
the information you'll discover by
expanding that selection
will include its series id which is the
end point
because i know you can barely contain
your curiosity i'll click through
and show you that it turns out that
level 11 computer and
mathematical professions in austin round
rock texas
could expect to earn 51 dollars and 76
cents
an hour back in 2019 so how do you turn
those series ids into python friendly
data
manually writing get and put requests
can be very picky and it'll take a lot
of tries before you get it exactly right
to avoid all that i decided to go with a
third-party python library called
bls that's available through oliver
sharosa's
github repo you install the library on
your host machine using
pip install bls that's all it'll take
while we're here we might as well
activate our bls api key
you register for the api from this page
and they'll send you an email with your
key
and a validation url that you'll need to
click
once you've got your key you export it
to your system environment
on linux or mac os that would mean
running something like this
where your key is substituted for the
fake one i'm using here
i'm going to use the api to request u.s
consumer price index
cpi and wage and salary statistics
between 2002
and 2020. the cpi is a measure of the
price of a basket of essential consumer
goods it's an important proxy for
changes in the cost of living which
in turn is an indicator of the general
health of the economy
our wages data will come from the bls
employment cost index
covering wages and salaries for private
industry workers in
all industries and occupations a growing
employment index would at first glance
suggest that things are getting better
for most people however
seeing the average employment wage
trends in isolation
isn't all that useful after all the
highest salary won't do you much good if
your
basic expenses are higher still so the
goal is to pull both the cpi
and wages data sets and then correlate
them looking for patterns
this will show us how wages have been
changing in relation to costs
now let me show you how it actually
works with valid endpoints for the
two data sets we're going to be using
we're all set to start digging for
cpi and employment gold
importing these four libraries including
bls
will give us all the tools we'll need
pandas stands for python for
data analysis which is a library for
working with data as data frames
data frames are perhaps the most
important structure you'll use as you
learn to process large data sets numpy
is a library for executing mathematical
functions
against large arrays of data and
matplotlibe is a library for
plotting data in visual graphs of
various kinds
when importing a library you assign it
the name you'll use to invoke
it you can choose just about anything
but pandas
is often represented by pd numpy as
np and matplotlib is plt
i'm also importing the bls library that
we installed a bit earlier
that will be invoked using its actual
name bls
i'll execute that cell now i pass the
bls endpoint for the cpi data series to
the
bls get series command from the bls
library
the endpoint code itself was of course
copied from the popular data sets page
on the bls website
i'll assign the data series that comes
back to a data frame
using the variable cpi and then save the
data frame to a local
csv file this isn't necessary but you
might find it easier to work with the
data when it's saved locally
next i'll load the data from the new csv
file using the pandas
pd read csv command against the file
name
i'll assign the variable name cpi data
to the
new data frame that comes out the other
end running
just cpi data will print out the first
and last five lines of the data frame
the date column contains month and year
values
and the second column contains our
actual data
i'd like to simplify the headers to make
them easier to work with
so i'll use the pandas columns attribute
i definitely prefer it this way
however we'll need to also see the wages
data to know whether the formatted uses
is compatible with our cpi set so i'll
pull the wages data series using the
bls library and assign it to the wages
data frame
once again i'll save it to a local csv
file and
read that data into a new data frame
called df
i'll clean up my column headers and use
head to print only the
first five lines of data you should
notice two things
this data isn't delivered in monthly
increments but quarterly
with only one entry for every three
months and the date format is different
instead of a month number there's q1
or q2 if you want python to sync between
our two data sets
we'll need to do some editing i'll do
that by replacing
every march data point meaning any date
entry containing the string
dash 0 3 within its date value
with the string q1 june
that is a string including dash 0 6
will get q2 and so on as you can see
now when i print just the date column
some values have been updated to the new
format
but the rest of them are from this point
unnecessary and will cause us trouble
so we'll have to get rid of them all
together i'll do that by creating a
new data frame called new cpi and
reading into it
the contents of the old cpi data data
frame
but i'll use the pandas string dot
contains function
to identify all the rows in the data
frame that contain a dash
and by specifying false dropping them
we'll be left with only properly
formatted quarterly data points in our
set
i'll save this data frame to a csv file
too
notice how we've dropped from 232 rows
to just 77. just because i'm paranoid
i'll create a new data frame called new
df so the old
df data frame will still be available to
me
should i accidentally make a mess with
what we're about to do next
with our data all neatened up we're
ready to begin our analysis
we've got a big problem here the data in
the cpi set comes in
absolute point values while the wages
are reported in
percentages measuring growth
as is there's no way to accurately
compare them
for one thing each row of our wages data
is the percentage by which wages
whatever is in that quarter
had the current rate continued for a
full 12 months
so not only do those values not
correspond to the
absolute cpi price data they're not even
technically true
of their own time frame so when we're
told that the rate for
the first quarter of 2002 was 3.5
percent
that means that if wages continue to
rise at the current
first quarter rate for a full 12 months
the annual
average growth would have been 3.5
percent but not 14 percent
which means the numbers we're going to
work with will have to be adjusted
that's because the actual growth during
say the three months of 2002
quarter one wasn't 3.5 percent
but only a quarter of that or 0.875
percent
if i don't make this adjustment but
continue to map quarterly growth numbers
to quarterly cpi
prices then our calculated output would
lead us to think that
wages are growing so fast that they
become detached from reality
now i should warn you that solving this
compatibility problem
will require some fake math
i'm going to divide each quarterly
growth rate by four or in other words
i'll pretend that the real changes to
wages during those three months were
exactly one quarter of the reported
year-over-year rate
i'm sure that's almost certainly not
true and it's a gross
simplification however for the big
historical picture i'm trying to draw
here
it's probably close enough now that will
still leave us with a number that's a
percentage
but the corresponding cpi number we're
comparing it to is again
a point figure to solve this problem
i'll apply
one more piece of fakery to convert
those percentages to
match the cpi values i'm going to create
a function
i'll feed the function the starting 2002
first quarter cpi value of 177.1
that'll be my baseline i'll give that
variable the name
new num for each iteration the function
will make through the rows of my
wages data series i'll divide the
current wage value x
by 400 where'd i get that number 100
simply converts the percentage
to 3.5 etc to a decimal
0.035 and the 4
will reduce the annual or 12 month rate
to a quarterly rate covering 3 months
to convert that to a usable number i'll
multiply it by the current value of new
num
and then add new num to the product that
should give us an approximation
of the original cpi value adjusted by
the
related wage growth percentage but of
course
this won't be a number that has any
direct equivalent in the real world
instead it is as i said an arbitrary
approximation
of what that number might have been but
again i think it'll be close enough for
our purposes
take a moment to read through the
function global new num
declares a variable as global this makes
it possible for me to replace the
original value of new num
with the function's output so the
percentage in the next row will be
adjusted by the
updated value note also how any strings
will be ignored
and finally note how the updated data
series will populate the
new wages data variable let's check that
new data
looks great our next task will be to
merge our two data frames
and then plot their data don't go away
what's left we need to merge our two
data series so
python can compare them but since we've
already done all the
cleaning up and manipulation this will
go smoothly
i'll create a new data frame called
merge data
and feed it with the output of this pd
merge function
i simply supply the names of my two data
frames and specify that the date column
should be the index that wasn't hard
let's take a look
our data is all there we could visually
scan
through the cpi and wages columns and
look for any unusual relationships
but that defeats the point python data
analytics is all about letting our code
do that for us
let's plot the thing here we'll tell
plot
to take our merge data frame merge data
and create a bar
chart because there's an awful lot of
data here i'll extend the size of the
chart with a
manual fig size value i set the x axis
to use values in the
date column and again because there are
so many of them
i'll rotate the labels by 45 degrees to
make them more readable
finally i'll set the labels for the x
and y axes this is what comes out the
other end
because of the crowding it's not
especially easy to read
but you can see that the orange wages
bars are for the most part
higher than the blue cpi bars that means
that wages are experiencing a higher
growth rate than the cpi
we'll have a stab at analyzing some of
this a bit later
is there an easier way to display all
this data you bet there is
i can change the value of kind from bar
to line and things will instantly
improve
here's how the new code will work as a
line plot and with a grid
python along with its associated
libraries
gives us the ability to use a much wider
variety of plotting tools than just
bar and line graphs we're going to
explore just two of them here
scatter plots and histograms we'll also
talk a bit about how regression lines
work
and what kinds of insights they can show
us we'll begin with scatter plots
this code is from the property rights
and economic development chapter on my
teach yourself data analytics website
you can catch up on the background
over there but the code you're looking
at comes from two data sources
the world bank's measure of per capita
gross domestic product by country
and the index of economic freedom data
from the heritage.org site
i merge data from the two data frames
into this one called
merge data i'll create a simple scatter
plot with this one line command
we can clearly see a pattern the higher
the per capita gross domestic product
meaning
the more economic activity a country
generates
the further to the right on the x-axis a
country's dot
is likely to fall and the further to the
right the higher is the economic freedom
score
of course there are anomalies in our
data there are countries whose position
appears
way out of range of all the others it
would be nice if we could somehow see
which countries those are it would also
be nice if we could quantify the
precise statistical relationship between
our two values
rather than having to visually guess
we'll begin by visualizing those
anomalies in our data to make this
happen
i'll import another couple of libraries
that are part of the
plotly family of tools you may need to
manually install them on your host using
pip install plotly before those will
work
from there we can run px scatter
and point it to our merged data data
frame associating the
score column with the x-axis and value
with the y-axis so we'll be able to
hover over dot and
see the data it represents we'll add the
hover data argument and tell it to
include
country and score data this time when
you run the code you get the same nice
plot
but if you hover your mouse over any dot
you'll also see its data values
in this example you can see that the
tiny but
rich country of luxembourg has an
economic freedom score of 75.9
and a per capita gdp of more than 121
thousand dollars
you can similarly pick out other
countries at either end of the chart
we can learn more about the statistical
relationship between our values by
adding a regression line a measure of
the data's
r squared value we already saw how our
plot showed a visible trend
up and to the right but we also saw
there were
outliers can we be confident that the
outliers are the exceptions
and that the overall relationship
between our two data sources is sound
there's only so much we can assume based
on visually viewing a graph
at some point we'll need hard numbers to
describe what we're looking at
a simple linear regression analysis can
give us a measure of the strength of the
relationship between a dependent
variable
and the data model r squared is a number
between
zero and one hundred percent where one
hundred percent would indicate a
perfect fit of course in the real world
a 100
fit is next to impossible you'll judge
the accuracy of your model or
assumption within the context of the
data you're working with
how can you add a regression line to a
pandas chart
there are as always many ways to go
about it i like
simple and the ols trendline approach is
about as simple as it gets
just add a trendline argument to the
code we've already been using
that's it ols by the way stands for
ordinary
least square which is a which is a type
of linear regression
and here's how it looked with our
regression line when i hover over the
line
i'm shown an r squared value of 0.55
or in other words around 55 percent for
our purposes
i'd consider that a pretty strong
correlation
a histogram is a plotting tool that
breaks your data down into
bins a bin is actually an approximation
of a
statistically appropriate interval
between sets of your data
bins attempt to guess at the probability
density function
pdf that will best represent the values
you're actually using
but they may not display exactly the way
you think especially
when you use the default value i'll
illustrate how this works or
actually how it doesn't work using data
from the do birthdays make elite
athletes chapter on the website
as you can see over there i'd scrape the
semi-official nhl api for the birth
dates
of around 1100 current nhl players my
goal was to
visualize the distribution of their
birth dates across all 12 months
to see if their births were concentrated
within a specific
yearly season when i displayed the data
using a histogram
we didn't see the pattern we'd expected
in fact the pattern wasn't truly
representative of the real world
that's because histograms are great for
showing frequency distributions
by grouping data points together into
bins this can help us
quickly visualize the state of a very
large data set where
granular precision will get in the way
but it can be misleading for use cases
like ours
since we were looking for a literal
mapping of events to calendar dates
even setting the bin amount to 12 to
match the number of months
won't help because a histogram won't
necessarily stick to those exact borders
what we really need here is a plain old
bar
graph that incorporates our value count
numbers
i'll pipe the results of value counts to
a data frame called
df1 and then plot that as a simple
bar graph in the next module we're going
to talk about
understanding our data visualizations
and integrating what we see in our
jupiter notebooks
with stuff that happens out there in the
real world
stay tuned we're supposed to be doing
data analytics here so just staring at
pretty graphs probably isn't the whole
point
the cpi and wages data sets we plotted
in the previous chapter
for instance showed us a clear general
correlation
but there were some visually
recognizable anomalies
unless we can connect those anomalies
with historical events
and explain them in a historical context
we won't be getting the full value from
our data
but even before going there we should
confirm that our plots
actually make sense in the context of
their data sources
working with our bls examples let's look
at graphs to compare
cpi and wages data from both before
and after our manipulation that way we
can be sure that our math
and particularly our fake math didn't
skew things too badly
here's what our cpi data looked like
when plotted using the raw data
it's certainly a busy graph but you can
clearly see the
gentle upward slope punctuated by a
handful of
sudden jumps next we'll see that same
data
after removing three out of every four
months data points
the same ups and downs are still visible
given our overall goals
i'd categorize our transformation as a
success
now how about the wages data here
because we moved from percentages to
currency
the transformation was more intrusive
and the risks of misrepresentation
were greater we'll also need to take
into account the
way a percentage will display
differently from an absolute value
here's the original data note how
there's
no consistent curve either upwards or
downwards
that's because we're measuring the rate
of growth as it took place within each
individual quarter
not the growth itself now compare that
with this
line graph of that wage data now
converted to
currency base values the gentle curve
you see
makes some sense it's about real growth
after all not growth rates
but it's also possible to recognize a
few spots where the curve steepens
and others where it smooths out but why
are the slopes so smooth in comparison
with the percentage-based data
look at the y-axis labels the index
graph is measured in
points between 180 and 280
while the percentage graph goes from 0
to 3.5
it's the scale that's different all in
all
i believe we're safe concluding that
what we produced is a good match with
our source data
establishing some kind of historical
context for your data
will require looking for anomalies and
associating them with
known historical events that's something
i do at length in the
wages and cpi reality check chapter on
the website
if you're interested i'm sure you'll
work through that material on your own
but i think you've seen enough here to
get a picture of how plotting the
right visualization can be helpful but
that brings us to the end of this
particular course
as i've mentioned a number of times
already the full curriculum is available
on my
thedataproject.net and you're more than
welcome to join all the cool kids over
there
and be in touch if you've got something
to add to the conversation
the main thing is to realize that the
end of this course
isn't anywhere near the end of your data
analytics education
watching me calmly execute nice clean
code samples
isn't really learning unless you're a
very special breed of genius
you won't begin to understand how all
this really works
until you dive in and work things
through yourself i say
work things through but what i really
mean is
not work things through because it's
mistakes and frustration
that are the best teachers don't imagine
that my python code just came to exist
on a
quiet afternoon while i was sipping nice
hot coffee
first of all i don't drink coffee but
more to the point
there was nothing quiet about it there
were humiliating failures
reformulations start overs and countless
trips to stack overflow
before things began to take shape but
the more problems i faced and overcame
the deeper the process sank into my mind
and the better i got at it
and so will you just be prepared for
tough times ahead before you all run off
and get on with your day
let's spend a moment or two reviewing
everything we saw here
we spoke about the many ways you can
work with jupiter notebooks
including online platforms like google's
collaboratory
and locally hosting either jupiter lab
or classic notebooks
we then introduced ourselves to the
jupiter environment
learning about cells kernels and the
operating environment
we saw how we can find data through
public apis and
how to integrate api credentials into
our python environment
python libraries and modules were our
next focus
including how to import appropriate
libraries to allow us to
effectively clean and manipulate our
data
and finally turning to some actual data
analytics
we learned some basics of plotting
including working with scatter plots
regression lines and histograms and we
closed out the course with a quick
discussion
of how to use our data visualizations to
integrate our insights
with the real world i hope this has been
helpful for you and i invite you to
check out
some of my other content on my main
website bootstrap.it.com
take care